we continue to learn more about Donald
Trump firing Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson the initial line that we heard
explaining the firing was that Tillerson
was notified of the firing last Friday
and it was over disagreements with Trump
over trade and possibly how to handle
the North Korea situation and very
quickly that explanation started to look
pretty dubious because Tillerson
spokesman said Tillerson didn't find out
about the firing Friday he found out
about it when Donald Trump tweeted about
it earlier this week and that led us to
look more deeply into the timing and
wonder whether this actually has
something more to do not so much with
Tillerson views on trade in North Korea
but the fact that Tillerson endorsed the
official UK position that Russia had its
hands all over the recent nerve gas
poisoning of a former Russian spy in the
UK while the White House had not at
least up until that point accepted that
there was another possibility related to
Russia this one a little more complex
related to ExxonMobil which Rex
Tillerson was formerly the CEO of
pulling out of a possible Arctic
drilling deal with Russia and Tillerson
not intervening to help keep it in place
in other words to Russia related
explanations but now we have a new and
possibly even more interesting
hypothesis which comes to us from Sigurd
Neubauer
in the foreword which suggests that
actually the underlying motive for
firing Rex Tillerson might have been
Donald Trump's desire to protect his own
son-in-law Jared Kushner and this
requires a little bit of explanation
Tillerson and Kushner were actually on
opposing sides of an incident that ended
up exposing a bunch of information about
Kushner that's really not great for him
and you might remember we've talked
about this a little bit a cushion errs
family owns this building in Manhattan
called 666 Fifth Avenue okay and it's
been financially in disarray it's a real
estate venture that has not gone
particularly well for the cushion or
family tons of debt the Kushner's have
been trying to get financing for the
property and if this is ringing a bell
it's because I did talk about this a few
months ago Jared Kushner
Emily was trying to get financing for
this project from an investment group in
Qatar and as I mentioned before the
Qatari group ultimately said now we're
not interested we're not going to go
forward with this project and then weeks
later there was a new blockade put in
place against Qatar by Saudi Arabia the
United Arab Emirates Bahrain and Egypt
later on we found out that Donald Trump
was very much in favor of that blockade
and that part of the reason Trump was so
in favor of it is that Jared Kushner was
pushing Trump hard to support it we now
have also learned that outgoing former
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson was
completely opposed to Donald Trump
supporting that blockade and now we've
learned that Tillerson was reportedly
furious about this and directly blamed
Kushner in other words said it's
Kushner's fault that Trump is doing this
thing that I vehement ly disagree with
there's a close associate of Tillerson
x' who said to reporters rex put two and
two together and concluded that this
absolutely vacuous kid was running a
second foreign policy out of the White
House family quarters now there's two
reasons why Jared Kushner might have
supported this blockade on Qatar the
sort of more well-known but maybe less
plausible one is it was just revenge
right Jared Kushner was angry that the
Qataris were not going to fund his real
estate project and he wanted to punish
them with a blockade a financial
blockade the other one here is that that
is increasingly more plausible although
it's been less discussed is that Kushner
is tied to the UAE
and that it was the UAE the Emirates
that were aggressively pushing Kushner
to push Trump to push for this blockade
either way
the big picture is that more and more it
seems that Rex Tillerson was right that
Jared Kushner was influenced by whether
you like the 666 fifth avenue story or
the UAE story whichever one of those are
both you believe the idea here is that
Tillerson was right Tillerson put two
and two together and that the firing of
Rex Tillerson was actual
to protect Jared Kushner because Trump
knew that Tillerson had figured out what
Kushner was doing and why he was so
aggressively pushing Trump on this and
he figured out some of the underlying
reasons why and that by getting rid of
Tillerson he's protecting Kushner and
just getting Tillerson square out of the
way now I don't know if this is the
quote real explanation I don't know if
it's the Russian nerve gas explanation
or the Russian Arctic drilling
explanation but what's super clear at
this point is that the simple and clean
and tidy explanation of oh he was
removed over disagreements on trade
tariffs and North Korea that's the least
believable of all of the explanations
that we've seen so far send me your
thoughts what do you think is the real
reason here that Rex Tillerson was fired
so abruptly by Donald Trump I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is brought to you in part by
celcius which is a new global
peer-to-peer financial platform that
connects holders of cryptocurrency
assets with borrowers and it will also
allow crypto holders to earn interest on
their assets in the form of coins or get
US dollar loans against their crypto
assets it's sort of like how having a
savings account at a bank works right
just by having crypto and your Celsius
wallet you'll earn interest on that
crypto but unlike a bank
this is blockchain based your coins
become part of a decentralized and
crowd-sourced lending pool and you'll be
able to earn interest daily without the
profits going to traditional financial
institutions and you can instantly
borrow against your own coins and
Celsius intends to lend only with
single-digit interest rates regardless
of credit score and Celsius sort of
wants to stick it to Wall Street and
revolutionize the financial industry and
they are running an IC o----
an initial coin offering which you can
learn more about at Celsius Network
slash crowd sale in the US it's open
only to accredited investors and you
sign up at Celsius dot Network slash
crowd sale this is not financial advice
please do your own research and due
diligence before making any financial
decision